ladies and gentlemen very good evening
to you I have that thank you president
Pavel it's a pleasure to be here
and it is a rather spontaneous and short
notice visit so I really thank you for
making it possible because we were not
able to meet in Brussels and I was sorry
for that so thank you very much that it
was possible to meet here in Prague and
seeing each other in this beautiful city
in this amazing Castle is a very big
impression on me too first of all I
wanted of course to congratulate you
personally on your election
and I want to thank once again czechia
for a very successful Council presidency
in the second half of 2022
concerning our meeting today I'm very
much looking forward to a close
corporation on many topics but mainly of
course also on topics related to Ukraine
we discussed it intensively
the European Union and the member states
as you know are strong supporters of
Ukraine so far the overall support is
worth 68 billion euros but it is also
the daily tangible help that needs to
continue
and that's why I want to expressively
thank the Czech Republic and its amazing
people especially for the exemplary
solidarity with Ukraine and the
Ukrainian refugees
I am aware that the Czech people
welcomed and provided assistance to the
highest number of Ukrainian Refugee per
capita this is outstanding and amazing
I'm really grateful for that
you president just returned from Ukraine
you told me once again that one of their
most urgent demands is ammunition
member states have already agreed to
provide further financing for supply of
ammunition now I am glad to be able to
announce today that the European
commission will propose tomorrow in our
College meeting
an act on in support of ammunition
production in Europe
so this act will support the ramp up and
the speed up of the manufacturing of
ammunition in Europe
it will combine leaner regulation with
Swifter permitting procedure it's all
about speed speed and scaling up now the
production of ammunition because Ukraine
needs it now
The Proposal will include EU funding of
500 million euros
and this is adding up to around 1
billion euros in total with the member
states co-financing the Euro the
European commission's funding of 500
million
this is good news for Ukraine it's also
good news for Europe's capability to
defend itself we are for sure in this
together
and another thing is for sure that check
and the European Union will stay in
United are united and face jointly the
geopolitical challenges to come many
thanks again for receiving me here
um
foreign
[Music]